all right six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty we are continuing to
take phone calls we're gonna go next to
our caller from the seven one six area
code caller from seven one six go ahead
hi David this is a Brendon from Buffalo
my question was if you had any
recommended reading or like some
favorite books something along those
lines just in general I mean yes I read
I don't know like 50 books a year so if
you have a genre fiction nonfiction what
are you what are you looking for
definitely leaning on the nonfiction
side so yeah if you had any even yeah
maybe more recent books or anything
you've read more recently something that
comes to mind yeah sure so recently
number one I've been getting into the
very short introduction series I read
the one on game theory the one on
prehistory the one on what else did I
read game theory prehistory I'm reading
the one on the history of Buddhism right
now which is very interesting so those
are interesting Daniel Kahneman's book
Thinking Fast and Slow is excellent I
recently read that I've been reading
quite a bit of oh I read fear and
loathing on the campaign trail by Hunter
s Thompson about the primary and general
election of 1972 those are like five
recent books I've read and check out
pakman.com slash recommendations oh yeah
that's right if you go to david
pakman.com slash recommendations you'll
see a long list of books I've read
awesome thank you very much all right
appreciate it thanks so much for the
call we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 this is the last time we're taking
calls for the year so we're gonna try to
hear from a bunch of people